ladies and gentlemen i set out to find
the biggest scammers
this year the year of the covid the year
of the scammer
and i think i succeeded i have five
for you and we're rating them from one
to ten on a scumbag scale
guys we have people who bought strippers
with loan money we have people who lied
about the cause of coronavirus who
promised immunity
well let's say it hasn't been tested on
this strain of the coronavirus but
it's been tested on other strains of the
coronavirus and
has been uh able to eliminate it within
12 hours
we have people you won't believe so stay
to the end so i can give you the number
one
scammer of this year in my opinion but
before we get into that let me just say
this
look covet 19 has caused so much more
damage than just the people who got sick
i mean i think that's the most obvious
thing
but because of how many people who don't
have jobs it's never been a better time
to be in the scam game
why because scams do well when people
are desperate
when people need something when they
have some incurable problem they need
fix
the snake oil salesman can come in make
a quick buck it's music to the snake oil
salesman's ears
when they hear oh gosh i would do
anything if and so i think it's
extra important now more than ever that
we expose these people
for who and what they are so without
further ado let's just get into the
let's get into this list shall we look
at number five on the list
have been these so-called small
businesses
getting loans with the ppp and they're
not actually small businesses
right they do over a billion dollars in
revenue for example
atlantic diving supply we've been over
this in another video you can go watch
it here
or here they have several billion
dollars in revenue
and they're getting small business loans
for millions of dollars we also have
people like
kanye west kanye west makes more in a
day
than i do in a year they got a small
business loan for millions of dollars
we were told when all this started that
this wasn't going to happen that
these small business loans they're going
to the the american people a little mom
and pop shop
you know abuelos down the road but again
the intent of this money was not for big
public companies that have access to
capital
that's where they're going they're not
going to the big guy it's not for the
big guy
and it just turned out to be a total lie
the 350 billion
dollar payment protection program
quickly ran out of money
that handed out millions to corporations
and left small businesses
without a dime uh this this is just pure
greediness
and you're taking away from your fellow
americans the people who actually need
this money
i will comment there have been some big
businesses that have taken these loans
i was pleased to see that shake shack
returned to the money
don't worry guys don't worry about
corruption in our government shake shack
return the money guys
hey no problem here shake shack return
the money
but i'm only going to give it a 5.5 out
of 10 for scumbaggery
and i'll explain why look it is bad
but at the end of the day if they are
actually paying out their employees with
that
and they're keeping more employees it's
not it's bad but it's not as bad as what
we're going to get into
number four though we've also got ppp
loans dude this has been
the source of some of the biggest fraud
and these are the people who get the ppp
loan
by fabricating government documents
saying i have this big business you know
just believe me government i have all
these employees that i'm paying out
and they actually don't and then they go
spend that money on things that have
nothing to do with their
you know imaginary business for example
there have been people who've gone to
vegas with the money
justice department released this
surveillance photo showing 40 year old
andrew marnell sitting at a blackjack
table in vegas
fraudulently received more than 8
million using fake applications
there have been people who bought lambos
with the money recently in texas
a guy up the enemy he didn't just buy a
lambo he got strippers and a lambo he's
out doing david hines david hines
from florida who talked about the pvp
chronicles he only did the he just did
the lambo baby
this guy's up in the game he's saying no
no if you want to be a true scumbag
you got to get the strippers with the
lambo and he allegedly spent the money
on strip clubs and nightclubs
a lamborghini rolex watch and used some
of the money to buy
a new pickup truck oh i forgot that too
he also got a rolex and a pickup truck
have you no shame dude if i got illegal
money from the government
why would you go spend it immediately
that's like a total red flag you're
going to get yourself caught
which is why i believe that you know
only the most obvious cases of fraud are
getting prosecuted i
guarantee you there's 95 of these cases
a fraud will never get discovered so i'm
going to put that as number four
on our list uh 6.5 out of 10 i would say
on the scumbag scale and i would have
rated it higher
but they're ultimately stealing from the
government not from
amer the american people and as you'll
see our top three
they're just literally stealing from
poor desperate people i mean that's what
these guys are all about
so let's jump into the top three shall
we at number three on the list we have
mark chang now this guy is a real
character because he's got a whole past
he's actually sort of a celebrity
for his animal rights work my name is
mark ching
i'm the founder of the animal hope and
wellness foundation
which kind of has its own problems with
it which i'm not going to get into
here but mark ching his big thing that
he's been
gotten in trouble for and why he's
scamming people is because
he invented a little uh nutraceutical
that supposedly would
prevent covet 19. it would strengthen
your immunity to covet 19.
now what did he base this off of
absolutely nothing right he is no proof
of this it was thrive a little cbd thing
right
he's like the quintessential california
guy who thinks that weed and cbd is
going to cure you of
literally every disease known to man and
he got busted by the ftc
and with good reason i'm gonna rate that
a seven out of ten
because you're not taking money from the
government in this case
you're taking money from like desperate
old people who want to cure themselves
of covet 19 or strengthen their immunity
before they get it now from here on out
the top two
it's a tight race now the second biggest
covet scam that i've seen
come out comes from jim baker now you
guys may know
jim baker from a little little clip
let me play it for you real quick where
he said that silver could cure the
coronavirus
this influenza that is now circling the
globe
you're saying that silver solution would
be effective
well let's say it hasn't been tested on
this strain of the coronavirus but it's
been tested
on other strains of the coronavirus and
has
been hey from the world
stop look at that flashing in the lower
thirds
eighty dollars a hundred and twenty
dollars look you can get
jim baker's birthday special for silver
solution four ounce gels
for just eighty dollars what what a
gentleman
to give that away like that look at that
now
what's funny is no one ever did a
follow-up piece on this but i think
there's some funny stuff that happens
after it
because after claiming all this stuff
jim baker says he never said that he
never said
he never said it right and so here we
are
in a place by the way sorry for stopping
but
notice the still bottom third he's still
selling stuff
the cub go generator make checks payable
to jim baker show
over one word said on the show basically
was
was not even me that's right who was it
it was our guest dr cheryl salmon and he
throws it right under the bus
[Music]
he's like look i didn't even say it all
i said was
so you're saying you're saying that
silver's solution would be effective
[Music]
oh i love this guy dude he also
complains that look
he's not even allowed to get credit card
payments anymore you got to send him a
check otherwise he's going to be broke
the warfare continues
with our credit card company the company
that
processes credit cards we were notified
that because of the negative news
they have put a hold on all our funds
and within two weeks we will be totally
financially broke two weeks you only got
two weeks
all of that corona money and you only
got two weeks of savings
jimmy hey save it up
buddy i don't know about that but i yeah
i'm gonna go ahead and rate that an 8.5
out of 10.
using people's faith to scam them into
believing in your little silver solution
cures
absolutely hate that but
it all pales in comparison to our number
one spot
now i'm going to be honest most of you
probably haven't heard of this company
but you're going to be shocked when you
do
golden sunrise nutraceuticals recently
are getting shut down by the federal
trade commission
and the fbi just raided their warehouse
after it was discovered that they were
selling a drum roll please
twenty three thousand dollar corona
virus cure
that's right apparently some of their
supplements including immune stem
affectivate interferons are uniquely
qualified
to treat and modify the course of
coronavirus epidemic in china and other
countries
and that users can expect the
disappearance of viral symptoms
within two to four days just twenty
three thousand dollars guys no big deal
twenty three thousand dollars look i
swear dude these scammers hear about the
coronavirus and they're so excited
because big problems make people
desperate and when people are desperate
you can take their money
now apparently in an investigation
a undercover investigator asked who too
i really don't know how to say it better
than that i apologize
the president and executive officer of
golden sunrise pharmaceutical inc
and golden sunrise nutraceutical an
undercover investigator
asked them hey my mother's sick she's 68
she has coven
and the investigator asked if she should
take her mother to the hospital this
person
apparently said no you cannot go in
there instead
why don't you just buy our products
that's right 68 year old grandma
sounds like a customer to me i mean i
don't even know what to say at this
point
um this is so far off the scumbag
scale you know cause not look it's the
triple threat
you're lying in your advertising you're
stealing from poor people
and you're taking advantage of a tragedy
i literally don't know what else to say
and i guess what caps it all off is this
video that apparently one of their uh
you know people released where they're
trying to calm down their facebook group
about you know what's going on they're
saying hey it's no big deal
this came in the
newspaper today this is the newspaper
today by the way that's just an article
about how their
office was rated to give a real quick
little explanation
and let you know we're here
we're fine it's
all good uh it's not
all good hey it's not all good when
you're selling a twenty three thousand
dollar treatment plan of cover 19.
it's not good no but nothing's good
about this
oh i can't imagine we hear fbi
it's like oh what's going on what's
happening i know
what you know and yes the fbi was here
yes they did a search
and i'm just going to tell you
we're fine we're good sounds like the
speech jake paul
said to his team probably hey guys we
got rated by the fbi but it's all good
i would say this price gouging makes
them the biggest
scumbags on earth 10 out of 10.
congratulations golden sun
nutraceuticals you win but don't worry
everything will be okay let me know what
you guys thought i mean i don't know is
everyone seeing what i'm seeing do you
think i missed anybody
uh you know i couldn't include everyone
in here there's a lot of scams that
happened this year
but let me know if you thought i should
have included anyone and um yeah that's
basically it
thanks for watching and don't forget to
smash like
and subscribe thank you
[Music]
[Music]
comes along